My parents moved to Rome when I was a baby.
So for me, the first memories of my life are linked to Rome.
I lived there for almost 20 years.
Therefore, this is what influenced a lot my character and my view of the world.
I went to German school in Rome, in the center of Rome.
I went to kindergarten, elementary school and also high school.
So all my career and school was done in the same place.
When I lived in Rome, I felt and acted like being part of all of this.
And now I feel much more like somebody...
...who is watching the things from outside the Ponte Sisto,...
...even Via Giulia, Piazza Navona, Campo de Fiori for us was a daily routine.
So now I realize even more today...
...how this way of living was influencing my way of looking at things...
...without knowing at that time.
So it was part of my life and I was not really taking too much attention,...
...even if we were into history and we were aware of what we saw.
Piazza Navona gives me special memories because we always met there at night...
...and it was always the starting point for our walks through the city.
The Giardino degli Aranci is a special place for me...
...because I went there when we had motorbikes in our teens,...
...spending quite some time overviewing Rome.
It's one spot which I think is very remarkable and unique and it awakes memories.
Rome always feels like home.